[Music]
6 40 here on a wednesday morning and now
it is time to join us
join once again with metro sheriff joe
lombardo for our morning cup of joe's
segment sheriff good to see you once
again
good morning john good to see you well
let's get into things here
sir there's been unfortunately across
the country a surge in attacks on the
asian-american community this is
somewhat con
connected to the coronavirus how is
metro working with the
large asian population we have here in
the valley to protect them and
make sure everybody's secure
yeah unfortunately that is occurring um
but
fortunately we have not seen that here
in clark county as of yet
but to answer your question we have a
very robust uh
relationship with the asian community in
particular the asian chamber commerce
and the asian american group
and all the other affiliated uh social
groups and
political groups that across the county
acros
in particular to the chinatown area we
spent
not a significant i wouldn't use the
word significant but we spent a great
deal of our time
on south central area command spring
valley area command
addressing the asian community
so i think our relationship with them is
probably as robust as any other
demographic
but we have not seen that but we've made
them aware of the important pieces to
make them aware of it
aware of their surroundings and ensure
they don't become victimized from folks
trying to cause harm absolutely
something we do certainly don't want to
see here in the valley
get going now also metro sheriff
lombardo we cover barricade situations
frequently here in the valley in fact i
think we counted about
one a day for the last three weeks
something along those lines
so a question we have is how does metro
determine when such a big response on
these barricade situations is needed
when someone is holed up somewhere
yeah there has been you know i don't
know what the issue is recently um there
has been a frequency
of those type of events occurring here
in the uh beginning of the year
we average right around 75 80 of those
in totality year over year and what what
occurs john is
is you know it's an unknown
our patrol officer is called usually um
reference a domestic violence situation
that's usually the majority of those
type of calls
because of the emotions involved and and
people um
may be armed or or some other device
that would cause harm to the local
residents and
and through those emotional episodes
that decide on for unknown reasons
that they're going to barricade in their
house and and they're going to force the
cops to make a decision for them and so
what happens to those is a patrol
officer
shows up the situation may unfold before
them or we may have some knowledge
before we arrive
and then the subject the primary suspect
says hey
i'm not coming out come in and get me or
i'm going to wait you out and decide
what i'm going to do with my own
personal life either commit suicide or
just give up
so that requires a lot of resources to
evacuate the surrounding apartments
if you notice recently there was one
where the guy set his own apartment on
fire
which in turn has an effect on all the
surrounding
uh residences that we have to deal with
ensure that we know
who's inside those residences we get
them evacuated
and we provide them safety and if
they're armed with the firearm
you know they could discharge around
right through the walls
that have an effect on unsuspecting
people so those it's very
resource intensive but the whole key is
life safety
life safety seeing stabilization
and the preservation of property we go
through that
hierarchy when we make decisions and
swat
is our our our best tactical unit
to contain those folks and along with
swat is negotiators
so they have they tried to talk them out
and it could take eight hours or it
could take two hours and that's why it
seems overwhelming
but just on that point though when
you're talking about a situation where
that
it's a tense situation emotions are
charged up does the presence of swot and
all the officers not that it's not
necessary but does that dial up the
temperature
when maybe the real resolution might be
to try and dial it down
yeah you know what you're exactly right
but in
in the cases of the of these if you
recall in my description
we don't have all those individuals
there in the early throes of it
it's escalated to a point where swot is
necessary
in order to de-escalate the situation
and and more often than not that
overwhelming show of force
uh changes the mindset of the individual
and that individual says hey
i i can't survive this uh or i'm not
accomplishing what i want to accomplish
and it is a benefit for
us the community and themselves um and
de-escalating that situation so it's
it's
it's really a opposite of what you are
thinking
and i would agree with your thought
process but in this situation it's not
let's switch gears and talk about school
uh k through third graders and ccsd go
back on monday some of them do anyway
how's metro getting ready for the return
to kids on campus
yeah that's that's great news i wish it
was just a little more robust than that
the uh well we we have a school program
that we do every year this is in
conjunction with the clark county school
police for those of them in the las
vegas community that don't understand
the school district has their own police
department and what we are is a force
multiplier for them we come in and
assist whenever necessary
um to address the that environment but
where we mostly get involved is
in the ingress and egress of the kids at
the beginning of the day
and the end of the day we provide some
safety for the
people coming to pick up the kids
ensuring that they're not getting caught
up in traffic or causing harm in the
local businesses when they decide to
leave school
and overwhelm the stores though all
those kind of things that you could
imagine
through mischief that kids would attempt
to do
but but our role is mostly before and
after
and then the school police provide that
protection
during the school day all right let's
finally very quickly sheriff talk about
the transition las vegas is going
through trying to get
beyond covet post pandemic on the resort
corridor
how might metro adjust uh law
enforcement on the las vegas strip at
the resorts
as we move forward and as more people
start coming back to las vegas
yeah that's a that's a that's something
that we're fully aware of
and you know and we're so used to
dealing with the insurgents of crowds
with our special events and everything
else
goes along with the the community of las
vegas but in this situation we did have
some adjustment of resources in the
strip corridor and
to include fremont street um so as
as the tourism diminished we pushed a
lot of those officers out into the
surrounding neighborhoods
to deal with you know daily crime and
then as the tourism
returns and to include convention spaces
uh all those staffed individuals that we
have in convention center area command
and downtown area command
will just be brought back into the fold
and uh
it's very um fluid it's very easy
for us to make adjustments in that
aspect and and actually i'm looking
forward to it and i mean it's
as you can imagine anybody else it's
very hard for us to
adjust just like it is for a person
looking for a job
in that environment to move resources
quickly and efficiently on a you know
short notice but we're aware of it we're
we're fully
uh ready to adjust
as well i'm sure you guys are um and
we're looking forward to it i think
we're all ready for some normal sheriff
lombardo thank you very much for joining
us this morning if you at home have a
question for the sheriff
you can submit it of course eight
newsnow dot com find that if it's
answered every wednesday
6 40